sally ist deutschlands erfolgreichste
you to you tube beckers und trocken sind
gerade der trend schlechthin für galileo
hat sie leckere sommer torten zum
nachmachen kreiert und im anschluss an
unsere sendung können sie sogar live mit
c backen
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
wels daher gerade immer noch etwas
saison ist habe ich mir gedacht mach ich
mal wieder ein rezept mit erdbeeren und
zwar gibt es einen objekt orte aus dem
kühlschrank das heißt ihr braucht keinen
backofen
nicht
ja auf jeden fall hat es das ist ganz
viel spaß gemacht und beim nächsten mal
wieder
wo muss ich so eine blöde mütze tragen
noch nicht